[Музика]
що з Mina cometa motors з
собою спостерігай переслідуй Накамура
привіт хлопці прийшов час уроку англійської
мене звати Наталія загін давайте почнемо
[Музика]
сьогодні я хотів би привітати моїх дуже
дорогих гостей
привіт, Влад, добрий ранок, як справи
сьогодні
чудово, дякую, тож давайте почнемо наш
урок давайте зробимо це давайте зробимо це
сьогодні ми поговоримо про огляд визначних пам'яток і
поїдемо за кордон, але перед цим давайте
перевіримо домашнє завдання добре добре готуйтеся
я перевірю вас, щоб домашнє завдання
було  щоб написати електронного листа на початку та
згадати важливу інформацію, тож
давайте подивимося на мій приклад, там є
електронний лист, але деякі слова відсутні, тому
введіть слова, будь ласка,
і Влад, ви допоможете мені,
так як ми виглядаємо з прогулянками чи  незабаром
музеї та погода давайте почнемо з
першого речення вгадайте, що я їздив до
Італії минулого тижня мм-хм моя мама та моя
сестра, що має бути тут номер один я
хочу я хочу з так добре з мамою
та сестрою давайте продовжимо ми мали
чудовий час, який  була гарна подорож
номер два фільм був теплим і сонячним
, напевно, це погода так браво гарне
номер три вранці ми пішли до
хм, куди вони ходили на роботу я бачу ні або
музей добре давайте подивимося
музеї так вранці ми  ходили в
музеї чи можете ви повторіть будь ласка
вранці ми ходили в музеї дякую
вам вдень ми ходили на це цього
разу на роботу так ми ходили гуляти
вечорами ми їли піцу пасту, яку ми
вже маємо з усіма можливими так піца
або паста  у ресторанах смачно, і
як ти маєш рацію мм-хм
Віолетта прямо скоро, скоро добре, тому я
хочу запитати, чи ти коли-небудь був в
Італії
так, ти іноді дуже любиш піцу,
це правильно, яке рішення добре, яка
твоя улюблена паста з піци, це залежить
який час доби я шукаю на
опівнічній службі перед вихідними
так, це спокій, звичайно, добре, він
друзі, щоб брати їх поїсти, але
зазвичай, щоб пообідати, я думаю, це минуло я
віддаю перевагу добре, чи можете ви запитати мене про піцу
макарони, то яку піцу з макаронами ви
віддаєте перевагу, я люблю макарони, а мій улюблений –
карбонара робити ніч, чи подобається вам паста з карбонара,
гарний вибір, але я віддаю перевагу бонусу ах це
, звичайно, чоловіки зазвичай їдять м’ясо добре,
давайте далі, тож давайте обговоримо електронний
лист  подивіться важлива інформація,
куди ви побували,
як довго ви там пробули, яка
погода, як ви робили, і ваші
відчуття. Ця інформація в
електронному листі подивіться, і ми обговоримо з
кров’ю, тому чи маємо ми інформацію
про місце, чому  чи дозволили вони дівчині
так, звичайно, що це було за місцем Нова Зеландія
є базою, тому він Італія Італія
маєток Бога як довго вона залишилася ах
давайте подивимося
мм-хмм знайдіть інформацію в тексті
минулого тижня так, але як довго так, я не  не
бачимо, ми цього не бачимо, тому вона згадала
, що була туди минулого тижня, але ви
не згадали, як довго вона там
пробувала.
що вони
зробили  чи вона сказала, що це було в музеях,
вони ходили, і вони робили це макарони
та відпочинок так, вони їли піцу та макарони, які
добре приготовані, і почуття, це
згадувало, як ви ставитеся до їхніх
проблем, це про їжу про
поїздку та кишечник у  Reaper, давайте подивимося, як
чудово провели час так, ми чудово провели час, це
було фантастичне свято, тому я думаю,
що, на вашу думку, електронна пошта в порядку з
точки зору завдань, ми пропустили лише всі,
тому сувора погода пропустила
з періодом
так, ми не  я не знаю, скільки вона пробула
там два дні протягом десяти днів, ми не
знаємо, тому будь ласка, будь ласка, згадуйте цю
інформацію в завданнях, давайте рухаємося далі,
і сьогодні ми продовжимо розмову про
транспорт, тож О, як ви думаєте, що
таке  місце, де це
я впевнений, що це Лондон так, як Лондон
о так, я був кілька разів випадковим хорошим я
люблю Лондон
я був там два рази і, сподіваюся,
скоро поїду знову, тож який
транспорт ви можете побачити тут  на картинці я
бачу там який транспорт бачу боси
я бачу велосипеди добре що це за водний
транспорт що це за транспорт
можна назвати човен я не бачу
тому що без добре це дошка ви
можете побачити бар це відомий червоний автобус
мм-хм хороший
велосипед Enza велосипед до побачення що  про це
, що це, це
канатна дорога так, це не те
саме в світі, та сама частина автомобіля знаходиться
в повітрі та використовує трос, тому канатна
дорога повторюється, будь ласка, канатна дорога, і ви,
хлопці, виправте зараз, ми  маю ці речі
тут, так що це велосипед велосипед велосипед
бос ага і що це за автобус,
це не звичайний автобус, ми називаємо його червоним
автобусом, і він повинен закритися так, ми називаємо
його двоповерховим двоповерховим автобусом,
це  канатна дорога канатна дорога це
текст і є ще один засіб
пересування подивіться на текст все добре
весь текст
добре, тому у нас є велосипед, у нас є канатна
дорога, добре - я все ще читав на огляді
- так, вертоліт, тому ми не  Не бачу
гелікоптера тут є ще один
транспортний гелікоптер у вас напередодні  я користувався
гелікоптером  ви коли-небудь пробували
використовувати гелікоптер, і ми йдемо далі,
ми збираємося читати і слухати
текст, зверніть увагу на ці речення.
Я в червоному двоповерховому автобусі,
найкращий спосіб побачити визначні пам'ятки Лондона,
ось Букінгемський палац, можливо, я побачу,
як королева надіслала мені повідомлення та звичайний
Тернер у Денні Бой
о шість три години спробуйте велотур, Саллі,
це дешевше, ніж взяти  автобус і більш
екологічно чистий, на мій погляд,
це найшвидший спосіб обійти
Alfie безумство на одній і єдиній Alfie
три години я їхав на канатній дорозі
через річку десятки я міг побачити всі
пам'ятки там, безперечно, цікавіші,
ніж автобуси o  r велосипеди це було чудово
Боббі Денверс у Бобі, а не Дені,
дві години, вибачте, але поїздка на канатній
дорозі не така захоплююча, як екскурсія на вертольоті, яку я
їздив минулого літа в той час свого життя,
не можу дочекатися, щоб знову поїхати Лілі Пайпер на
лілію  долина
дві години як щодо круїзу вздовж
Темзи на човнах, найбільш розслаблюючий
спосіб ознайомитися з усіма туристичними
визначними пам'ятками Лондона, поки що до побачення
добре, тепер завдання для вас,
будь ласка, вирішіть, чи речення нижче
правильно вірно неправильно чи в тексті не
сказано  і ми перевіримо це за п'ять секунд,
давайте, що ви думаєте про
номер один, це перший раз Саллі в
Лондоні, правда, неправильно або в тексті не
сказано, я думаю, що це правильно, ви думаєте, що це
правильно, ми все, що нам потрібно переглянути
попередній текст Я можу показати вам текст, не
хвилюйтеся, подивіться на текст, а
це Саллі, вона не вона, вона не говорить
про те, що вона абсолютно права, тому
в тексті немає інформації про ваш
перший візит до Лондона, давайте поїдемо з
туристами на велосипеді номер два
погане довкілля  nt це неправильно так правильно
і давайте перевіримо текст подивіться
танцюйте, що спробуйте велосипедний тур, це більш
екологічно, давайте підемо з
номером три Альфі віддає перевагу канатним дорогам, а не
автобусам, це правильно, правильно так,
і давайте перевіримо текст я їхав
на канатній дорозі  над річкою, безперечно
, захоплююче, ніж автобуси, давайте поїдемо
з наступним.
Боббі сподобалося летіти на вертольоті
Cali точно так, і знову це правильно,
давайте перевіримо текст, вибачте, але канатна
дорога
для неї не так захоплююча, як вертоліт, тому вона мала  час мого
життя, що означає, що це була фантастична
подорож, і останнє речення Лілі
думає, що річкові круїзи виснажливі,
означає, що ви виснажені, це неправильно,
так, це неправильно, їй сподобалося, що
так, давайте знайдемо інформацію в
тексті, тому давайте на борту найрозслаблюючіший
спосіб перевірити всі підземні
визначні пам'ятки, ми бачимо слово розслабляючий,
що означає, що це добре, це не втомлює,
погоджуюсь добре зараз я хочу запитати вас, який
тур ви б обрали  подивіться визначні
пам'ятки Лондона вертоліт двоповерховий автобус
або велосипед або, можливо, круїз що б ви
вибрали новий London Eye це
огляд визначних пам'яток, але я хочу запитати вас
про транспортні засоби подивіться мій
приклад я б поїхав  велосипедний тур, якби я
поїхав до Лондона, тому що це веселий спосіб
побачити туристичні визначні пам'ятки та
екологічно чистий, тому у нас є
двоповерховий вертоліт, човен чи
велосипед, який ви виберете,
я віддаю перевагу вертольоту та
вертольоту капітана. Вид на це
цікавіше  і більше огляду визначних пам'яток, і
це швидше, ви можете подолати набагато більшу
відстань,
так, дуже, але іноді це
дорожче, звичайно, так, але, ймовірно,
для студентів велосипед
цікавіший.
Лондон і ось мої
фотографії подивіться, що це за
Лондонське око так так, це Лондонське
око, так що повторюйте за мною Лондонське
око Лондонське око добре, а це
Біг Бен так правильно  це вежа Біг-Бен,
а як щодо цього, що це за
порушення, яке порушення, ага,
зазвичай люди це плутають, вони називають
це Лондонський міст, так, я знаю, але,
на жаль, Лондонський міст інший,
це Тауерський міст, тому повторюйте за
мною Тауерський міст  Тауерський міст добре, і
знову це Лондонське око Башта Біг Бен
Тауерський міст
так, і ми називаємо це Лондонське око,
Лондонське око так, Лондонське око, молодець,
чи пам'ятаєте ви ще якісь місця в
Лондоні, музей мадам Тюссо, і,
звичайно, багато парків  тому що
Лондон дуже зелене місто
так, я згоден, ви відвідали Лондонський
музей транспорту,
на жаль, ні, наступного разу вам
обов’язково потрібно піти, наші студенти, у них
був урок
у Лондонському транспортному музеї, тому
подивіться онлайн, добре, давайте рухатися далі, тому я
хочу, щоб ви прочитали  у книгах тут є
деякі скорочення, тож це люди,
будьте фанатом, поки що
гр і номер вісім чудовий
я O, на мою думку, TMP надішліть мені назад,
а два це або привід  tion
to або номер два зараз давайте
подивимося на текст ще раз, чи є у нас ці
приклади в тексті, знайдіть приклади,
будь ласка,
і давайте побачимо приклади так,
звичайно, лише з самого
початку напівдоброго так
GPL так привіт  люди вдячні пишіть мені назад
так, що щодо цього, на мою думку,
добре зроблено, тоді було чудово.
Завдання для вас, хлопці,
будь ласка, використовуйте ці скорочення, щоб
заповнити пропуски за п’ять секунд, а тепер давайте
перевіримо, як щодо крові номер один
я чудово проводжу час
номер два, ранок люди гарне свято
номер три номер три
Іман, тому, на мою думку, так, на мою думку,
круїз  це найкраще число чотири номер
чотири надішліть мені назад
так і останній і останній
це все для мене поки що до побачення
так, давайте перевіримо, а ви перевірите у
нас правильно  подобається
бабуся
ні, чому кожен раз студенти кажуть, що
не люблять бабусю, це легко, добре,
я зроблю все можливе, щоб пояснити їм легко,
не хвилюйтеся, тому сьогодні подивіться,
це знову моє зображення з
цією
вежою Біг Бена  Я можу сказати, якщо
ви бачите запитання, чи були ви коли-небудь
у Лондоні, відповідь «так», і вони
можуть продовжувати, тому сьогодні ми говоримо
про теперішній досконалий час, і я можу
продовжити, я був там у 2011 та 2013 роках, то в
чому різниця між цими?  два
речення ти коли-небудь був або я був
там це теперішній досконалий час
і ми маємо це речення в простому минулому,
яка різниця, ти знаєш,
так, це інший час, так що я
можу пояснити, наприклад, подивіться на
це речення  past simple у нас є
точні періоди часу в 2011 році в минулому
і 2017 році, тому коли ми маємо точний
період у часі, ми використовуємо past
simple, але якщо я говорю
про теперішній час і я пояснив свій
досвід, тому я поїхав до Лондона, я
повернувся  hom  e і тепер у мене є результат, у
мене є моє зображення, тому результат
відноситься до теперішнього часу, і я не
маю точного часу в реченні, тому
я використовую Present Perfect, тому ми використовуємо
теперішній досконалий час, коли ми  мати
завершену дію з результатом у
теперішньому і ми не бачимо часу, коли
це відбулося
давайте перейдемо далі, як ми складаємо речення
в теперішньому досконалому у нас є
підмет я він вона їсть і так далі і так
далі, тоді ми маємо  the auxilary have a
house і у них є питання до вас,
коли ми використовуємо has she has yes she he
and it is good
Браво та дієприкметник минулого часу дієслова
в третій формі, тому приклад I have
been to the park I є підметом  половина —
це пахвовий, а bin —
дієприкметник минулого часу дієслова to be say
давайте подивимося на таблицю у нас є
стверджувальні речення або позитивні
речення IOU we use we are they we
also use have but he she eat we use has
correct yes  добре з негативними реченнями,
які додають примітку або ми робимо короткі
форма з використанням haven't або hasn't і коли у нас
є запитальне або питальне
речення, ми ставимо exhilarate
на початок, але має і короткі
відповіді так, вони є або так, вона має і
так, ми маємо чи ні, вона не має,
давайте продовжуємо  і наші улюблені неправильні
дієслова люблять неправильні дієслова однаково,
тоді як граматику
це важко для нас, тому ми
збираємося використовувати ті самі неправильні дієслова, і нам
потрібно запам'ятати три форми правильних
дієслів інфінітиву минулого простого і
минулого частки, а для цього
Я попрошу вас виконати звичайну дієсловну
гімнастику добре, ви залишаєтеся сидіти, вам
не потрібно вставати, і ви робите з
нами, тому у нас знову є три форми, дозвольте мені
допомогти вам,
тому перша форма — руки вгору, руки вгору,
ви робите так  давай давайте зробимо це
знову
причастя минулого часу буде тут
до плечей, а потім ми покладемо його тут на
нашу талію гарне причасте минулого часу давайте
з першим центом, ви повторюйте
зі мною той самий цент цент цент,
чому тут, тому що маєте  подивіться на
фо  rmer те саме, тому знову пісок пісок
пісок пісок пісок пісок давайте підемо з
перервою розбитий зламаний Браво давайте з C
випити дивлюсь я бачу вибачте C так C давайте
з бігти бігти бігти бігти бігти Гамлет
бігти бігати бігти бігти бігти тому що
той самий запустити запустити запустити що щодо читати це
завжди читати читати читати читати читати читати ми
вимовляємо це по-різному, але ми пишемо
те саме давайте йти з cut знову і
останній принесіть читати приніс добре
і гра слів вони чекають зачекайте так і
ви зробили  t do the gymnastics, тому
що це звичайне дієслово, це не
неправильне правильне правильне
дякую, давайте йти далі, тому
я був у парку, і ще одне
речення, мої друзі пішли в
парк, яка різниця,
давайте обговоримо так, що робити  ти думаєш,
це різниця, що я був у
парку, а я пішов у парк, усі мої
друзі цього разу знову пішли назад,
тож у нас немає часу тут,
щоб у парку, до парку, я маю
на увазі  намети правильно пішли
прес  ent perfect have been here, так що у нас
є
перші речення про мене, добре, тому
тут є ще одна різниця
з дієсловом in і con, тому, коли я кажу, що я
прикріпився до парку, означає, що я пішов
у парк і повернувся з парку, тому
Я зараз тут, у класі, із
реченням, яке пройшло, це
інше,
тому мої друзі пішли в парк, і вони
все ще там,
вони не повернулися, це головна
різниця, вони пішли, і вони все
ще були засоби  що я повернувся,
а тепер я тут, у класі чи
тут, на дачі, ладно, ходімо далі,
для вас є завдання, у нас є п'ять
речень, і вам потрібно вирішити,
був чоловіком чи пішов, минуло десять
секунд і ми  збираюся перевірити це так
Влад давайте підемо з номером одного мого життя,
щоб з'їсти мене на літо, він повертається у
вересні, має гумку добре правильно ми до
ресторану, як тільки ми були хорошими розенном
Сам до музею, і вони залишили п'ять хвилин
тому
все одно
позов не її  e вона пішла в банк, вона
зробила браво
Наомі до його готелю до того, як вона була.
Браво, це дивовижно, фантастична
студентка, я вражений, давайте йти далі, так
що була чи має зброю, і
я збираюся використовувати маркери зеленого кольору  колір
був це зелений колір, використовуйте
правильний так, і цього немає, так, немає,
а червоного ніколи не було,
тому, коли я кажу вам, ви створюєте свої
речення, коли я вказую на вас червоні
мокасини, які вам потрібні, щоб створити
речення вона була, де в
музеї вона була в вона була
в музеї ходить до школи і я кажу
вам, що я був вдома в молодці
пішли у
вівторок парк добре, і він він був
у поїздці
дуже добре і  вона пройшла
гарну подорож ви можете назвати місця в
коді країни добре вони поїхали
в США молодці, а
тепер ваша черга
я вказую вам на червоний ринок,
наприклад, мій приклад  щоб бути
я був у Єгипті, а ви і
приклад дотепності  h пішов давайте йти з ми
це добре давайте перейдемо до часу вікторини це
буде невеликий тест, тому перше
речення він був у Єгипті правильно чи
ні так правильно правильно
добре ще одне речення ми намагаємося бути
простими Італія так правильне тому що  якщо ми
використовуємо past simple ми повинні використовувати ми
повинні мати періоди часу ми не маємо
періодів часу ні тому спробували так ми
спробували ямки в Італії ще один ми
пішли в супермаркет
він пішов вибачте так він пішов
супермаркет, тож домашнє завдання для вас
уявіть, що ви поїхали на відпочинок до Едеси,
правильні дурниці про те, як пересуватися,
як ті, і текст про Лондон і
використовуйте скорочення, які ми використовуємо наступного разу,
я збираюся перевіряти ваше домашнє завдання,
і це приблизно  нам потрібно припинити
урок, побачимось наступного разу, до побачення
[Музика]
певні публічні замки oho Dania
bravado thomas pakusa
стиль спілкування дистанція в Індокитаї novena token
також сиськи є деякий маленький період cuvee
nom Trevor все ще ви знаєте продюсерів
вічна балаканина  балаканини, але видалені, оскільки
вони завжди мають значення, щоб повідомити,
хто холодніший Чалмерс я зловив їх на
всій відстані двигун і я китаєць і
гуркіт пістолета і емоційна музика
одружився в його кімнаті його рідний таміл
шах егоїзм з нуля за червону
шашку з постом  нове шасі tambien
Khedive стегна над вільним у себе 92f
ви поділяєте багато нових проблем і
процвітайте більше реагувати на пластик
[Музика]
ви